how'd you get this I know a guy who
knows a guy who shot a guy
[Music]
yes that's us that's fantastic so to
kick things off I wanted to ask you have
you ever heard of the fan theory that
each John Wick film is about one of the
five stages of grief how do you respond
to that
um
yeah I remember seeing that we haven't
done anything like that intentionally
but if it's clinically
accurate
then I know that we're authentically
trying to I'm characters in grief so
there might be a correlation there
um I don't know what are the five stages
there's like grief sadness anger starts
with denial denial fourth one would be
depression depression but there's five
of them so yeah denial depression briefs
yeah we wanted to ask you why should
fans experience John Wick chapter 4 and
iMac because it's cool
um no actually counter and I started the
whole franchise because we like the
movie experience not just movies we've
experienced some of my best memories in
a movie theater
um piano decided when we were gonna do
something like this like we didn't think
anybody would ever see the first one so
we're like oh we better get ready to
show it on the iPhone but we're going to
shoot it like you know we're going to
try some anamorphic lenses we're gonna
try the big lens first we're gonna try
the big wide scale kind of symmetrical
or
super wide symmetrical editing kind of
thing we're like we're going to pretend
that we're somebody's going to say I was
gonna sit on the big screen cut you now
John Wick 4 was entirely shot to be seen
on the big screen on IMAX on the laser
projectors the big screen we pushed our
color range so far on this phone with
the highlights and the contrast which
of course on IMAX cleans not to mention
the sound it starts with the love of
Cinema and it starts with that with our
director Chads to helski and with me and
with the DP Dan laosen
um who's remarkable it goes into like
Cinema thinking about the lenses the
camera bodies uh looking at the framing
everything is thought in a cinematic Big
Frame format you know just the way all
of the composition all of the Aesthetics
are
aimed to that experience that impactful
environment is much more intense
pleasurable and memorable the first
punch of the movie is meant to shake
your chest and the last little bit of
soundtrack on the movie is meant to make
you choke up a little bit and it's hard
to get that from a smaller device but if
you're sitting in in the room surrounded
by other people that are on that same
emotional ride as you it's a completely
different experience let's face it right
one's complete immersion
sensory immersion one is a relationship
and I isolatory I'm holding a device I'm
sitting on the TV I'm sitting on my
couch but when you're in that IMAX
theater and the room is shaking and you
can feel the excitement or the sadness
or the trepidation or just the
exhilaration from the priest and next to
you you get a different experience out
of it this kind of a fun one so with
John Wick chapter four he goes all
around the globe in your mind do you
think John Wick is traveling commercial
is he going private stowing away yeah we
figure out that all the time actually
and it's for me in John with chapter
four he was moving through the and I I
hope it comes across that he's moving in
the underground in the Bowery King world
and so I always thought of him if he's
flying like he's in some container you
know he's part of some kind of he's not
commercial and it's not private it's
like you know it's I don't know shipping
he's like a shipping object cargo yeah
he's like cargo he's Contraband what was
it like I know you stopped by the IMAX
offices many times yeah
um what was it like for you to see it up
on the IMAX that's always at post if
people understand how long post goes it
was like 89 weeks for me it was a really
long post on this one and then you do
all the different versions for you know
HDR SDR you do the standard version and
then you have the IMAX version yeah and
people don't really understand I don't
get to see the whole movie put together
sound we do our sound in one place we do
our color in another place we do the VFX
in the third play the only time I get it
put together is when we do that last the
DCP the Final Mix of the movie and I
only get to see it two three times
before it's all done so we the last
thing we usually do in the post process
is IMAX the big one so when I sit in
that theater and I'm with my two or
three you know inner Inner Circle people
and we watch it for the first time it's
one of the first times for me as well
and when you see it I mean that's when
it really hits you about what you've
either achieved or failed or what you're
proud of what you're not
um as a director it's probably one of
the most satisfying most Electric
the feelings I've had on this whole
journey 10 years when you sit in that
theater and you know you and I'm
actually sitting there and you get to
feel it and hear it and see it for the
first time it does put a smile on your
face
[Music]